[Music]  we do a closure every three years at  each facility and that involves our  training all nearly up close to a  million liters of water we have the team  of Tyler's and at the moment for  removing all the old sealant they'll cut  that all out and replace it with new  sealant that takes about ten days to  cure  so the pools need to stay dry that  period by that works continue and in the  planning we've got a team of heating  specialists working on our heating  system are strapping it right back  cleaning everything recommissioning  let's start there  we try and do the closures we met  quietest deliverers a good time to  closer for solid is busy as Dudley Park  but the period over the holidays is  usually a quieter time and effects this  customers overall  you